Bà Nhật Vinh thoại, Sĩ Quýt Gah đơn.
Các giả của những giai điều vừa thời gian sẽ mêu dễ tệ Việt Nam.
Nhanh giấu 3 năm sợ người bấm nhạc.
Điểm nhạc, Sĩ Quýt Gah đơn, Lai Sĩ Việt Nam,
đưa tổ chứ bằng ngày 18 tháng mở tới đây tại Trung tâm Hộ Nhi Cú Già Hanoi.
Sự kiện là chính thường thứ ba thuộc trối dưới an anh nhà Quốc Tế vì cậu đầm,
giúp mò nình Việt Nam với một tiêu đưa tinh hoa âm nhạc thì giới đến khán giả việt.
Các quảng bá văn hoán lịch sử nước nhà sẽ có Tế.
Híc đôi đón bằng nhà ở sĩnh bay thì đây cũng là bằng nhà có số lượng người trong loa đến Việt Nam.
Dạc, người khoảng hơn 2 người và vải tấn tiếp tỉ.
Có lẽ là những cái sức sột biệt của bằng nhà của người là sức sử biệt bằng thuộc trước.
Chắc chắn sẽ mang lại một thi đêm nhà rất là đặc biệt.
Chúc đó, giữa anh đã khi giấu với 2 đêm em nhạc thành công là Kênh Ghi Gah đơn,
tham 5, 5, 5, 5, 5, 5, 5, 5, 5, 5, 5, 7, 5, 5, 5.
Sơn hưởng bản chủ đây, giống cho mặt tộc tự thiệt.
Chúng tôi đánh kế hoa cậu làm một biệt sĩ đi với một dạn nhạc sau hưởng.
và vì chủ tối rất thích ý tưởng, có thể là một bản phu dấu hình hoàn trình cho ông nhạc của chúng tôi.
Đó là một cảm giác tự sửi khi đe rằng ông nhạc có thể lan truyền tốt như vậy.
Phá trừng tôi luôn nghĩ rằng em nhà phóng người dưới vừa nào
vì vậy, là cả dừng tôi không phải nói tiếng gì vậy
đã tìm vào khi mọi người vẫn hiểu được bản chất của tôi về
và tình cảm chúng tôi đang làm
Bởi vì sĩ quýt gói đến lát tìm Việt Nam
khán giá sẽ có cơ hội thường thức chực tiếp at ở phẩm hồi tiếng
đã chiến phục hàng xeu trái tìm trên guản thế giới